es un fortalecimiento de lazos en la
visita del presidente de China chilla
Arabia Saudita para reunirse con los
principales líderes árabes consolida el
bloque en medio de las tensiones entre
el mayor exportador de petróleo del
mundo y Washington
construiremos un nuevo modelo de
cooperación energética tridimensional
china seguirá importando regularmente
grandes cantidades de crudo de los
países del ccg aumentará las
importaciones de gas natural licuado y
reforzará la cooperación en el
desarrollo de petróleo Y gasto
Aunque Esta visita de tres días fue
mucho más allá del petróleo las seis
potencias árabes ricas en recursos y
China la segunda mayor Economía del
mundo firmaron 46 acuerdos sobre
diversos temas por cerca de 30.000
millones de dólares Todo en busca de
beneficios económicos y estratégicos
para ambas partes sobre la mesa
aparecieron en la negociación de un
acuerdo de libre comercio e intercambio
de inversiones cercano a los 110
millones de dólares desde 2005 y también
el intercambio de tecnología tanto de
armamento como de telecomunicaciones
esta Cumbre establece una nueva fase
histórica de las relaciones entre China
y Arabia Saudita y pretendemos
profundizar la cooperación con china en
todos los sectores y coordinar puntos de
vista sobre asuntos regionales e
internacionales el ccg considera china
un socio esencial importante
un movimiento que reafirma que los
países del Golfo socios estratégicos de
Estados Unidos están fijando su vista en
Asia en busca de nuevas alianzas y una
menor dependencia de Estados Unidos